[موسيقى]
لا يزال الغموض سيده موقفي حوادث التسمم
في ايران ضحايا دون متهم وجريمه كامله
الاركان بلا مجرم الجديد لكنه ليس مستغربا
ان تعود جميع اصابع الاتهام التي اطلقها
النظام نحوه مباشره
فعمليه التصميم المنظمه والمنهجه التي
طالت حوالي 230 مدرسه في 25 محافظه وصممت
اكثر من خمسه الاف تلميذه هي براي مطلعين
من تخطيط داخلي منظمه وليس عشوائيا
استهداف الفتيات تحديدا مؤشر ثان على تورط
النظام في الجريمه البشعه والتي وان لم
تسفر عن وفيات يرجح انها تسبب حاله ذعر
مزمنه حاله تلبي حاجه النظام بقطع راس
ثوره امراه حياه حريه التي لا تزال مشتعله
لكن العكس تماما هو ما حصل فاليوم اندلعت
احتجاجات اولياء الطالبات على ما وصف
بالهجمات الكيماويه في كل من طهران وشيراز
والاهواز ورشت وبابل وبشهر وهمدان وزنجان
واردابيل وسننذج وكرمانشاه وكرج ومشهد
بعد ثلاثه اشهر من تسجيل اولى حالات
التسمم والتي اشتدت هذا الاسبوع تعلن
السلطات الايرانيه اليوم عن توقيف خمسه
مشتبهين دون الكشف عن هويتهم او حتى
الاعتراف بالتقصير بواجبها في حمايه
المواطنين
خارجياس
تخيل بيور زيد
يا ايها الجالسون التسمم التالي لابنائكم
والموت للنظام القاتل للاطفال شعارات اخرى
علقت وخطه على جدران المؤسسات الحكوميه
كلمات لا قد صدن خارج ايران وصدمه كبيره
في المانيا ودعوه من الامم المتحده
وامريكا لاجراء تحقيق مستقله يكشف سر السم
الصامت في انحاء ايران